[Music]
Jason Silva has been called houses for
description a Timothy Leary for the
viral video age wow where did your sense
of curiosity - do you know where it came
from
filmmaker and philosopher Jason Silva
looks at love loss and Technology in his
new youtube series shots of all human
beings are afflicted with this kind of
unbearable awareness of our own
mortality we are the only species that
loses sleep over the fact that one day
in the future we're gonna die so for
those who don't know my name is Jason
Silva I am the host of national
Geographics brain games which is a
television show that looks at our
perceptions of reality but also our
misperceptions of reality it does it
does it work if I it doesn't work if I
do that science finally sort of grounds
our metaphysical musings in an empirical
reality what it does for me is it
doesn't get rid of the mystery but it
sort of reassures me that what I was
experiencing was real multiple streams
of curiosity intersected a space called
fashion right and then once you've
identified your passion then you can
figure out how to turn that passion into
a purpose
what if being a billionaire in the age
of exponential technologies was not just
making a billion dollars would have been
a billionaire meant positively touching
a billion people is the processing
between your left wing and your right
brain if you really want to aim high you
know what to do with all of this
disruption to try to positively touch a
billion frames try to positively reach a
billion minds try to make the world a
little better by aiming to redefine the
term billionaire so I'll leave you with
that I hope you guys all go out there
and change the world thank you so much
for listening I love you so much thank
you guys thank you